[Music]
back to ground zero this family is
gathering what remains of a life
destroyed by the September 10th flots in
dharna they lost their home but count
themselves among the lucky ones
our condition is better than other
people you filmed and seen we thank God
we don't want anything more we're living
a proper life
cousins no trace of them or their house
only God knows they only found the body
of my uncle and his daughter made a soul
rest in peace
thousands of others remain missing the
official death toll is close to four
thousand but it's thought that number
could exceed ten thousand
the collapse of the dam divided the city
into two parts there was a bit of
difficulty in exchanging data initially
numbers varied between 10 and 20 000.
all of these were just speculative
numbers the public prosecutor's office
coordinated and now we are talking about
a unified number for everyone
unprecedented heavy rains burst the
cities to all dams unleashing a torrent
that Swept Away entire neighborhoods
into the sea the Mediterranean has
gained Grim reputation for claiming
lives of migrants attempting to cross to
Europe the dharnath tragedy has added
many unidentified bodies to its Waters
with some being recovered and identified
this is where identification happens the
body responsible for the search and
identification of missing persons is
operating several mobile Labs families
report their missing loved ones via
phone online or in person and provide
DNA samples for testing
the samples taken from unidentified
bodies are collected by the Department
of Welfare and forensic medicine the
bone samples are transported and we
begin working on them as it's done here
eventually we obtain a DNA profile for
the cases and they are compared through
a matching system until it provides us
with a match
but the scale of This Disaster is
enormous and it could be months before
survivors know anything about the loved
ones they lost Tripoli
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera